[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis
hat dich willkommen und guten Abend für
den Sport im Studio ist Norbert
Nebelscheinwerfer themenüberblick
Steinmeier vor der zweiten Amtszeit nach
SPD und FDP sprechen sich jetzt auch die
Grünen für die Wiederwahl des
Bundespräsidenten aus
Vorwürfe gegen den früheren Papst
Benedikt bisher geheime Unterlagen
sollen zeigen dass er sexualisierte
Gewalt nicht geahndet hat
und Gewalt bei Demos gegen Corona
Maßnahmen 10000 waren wieder auf der
Straße bei Ausschreitungen wurden
Polizisten verletzt
[Musik]
früher hatte angekündigt wieder zu
kandidieren jetzt kann sich Frank-Walter
Steinmeier ziemlich sicher sein als
Bundespräsident wiedergewählt zu werden
nachdem ihm dabei auch die Grünen
unterstützen sieht alles nach einer
komfortablen Mehrheit aus knapp sechs
Wochen vor der Bundesversammlung die den
Bundespräsidenten wählt Patricia
Wiedemeyer
es ist knapp fünf Jahre her dass Frank
Walter Steinmeier zum Bundespräsidenten
gewählt wurde seine Wiederwahl am 13.
Februar scheint nun sicher die Grünen
sie hatten lange gezögert hätten auch
gerne eine Frau im Amt gesehen
entschieden haben Sie sich jetzt aber
für den Amtsinhaber
hat Walter Steinmeier ist ein sehr
geschätzter und respektiert der
Präsident steht für Zusammenhalt für
unsere lebendige Demokratie und hat
immer klar Position bezogen gegen Hass
und Hetze ein Erfolg für die SPD und
auch die FDP hatte sich schon sehr früh
für Steinmeier ausgesprochen der sich
selber im Mai letzten Jahres für eine
zweite Amtszeit beworben hatte er ist in
der Bevölkerung
außerordentlich beliebt und über die
Parteigrenzen hinweg das anerkannte
Gesicht eines toleranten eines modernen
und europäisch ausgerichteten
Deutschlands und wir haben einen guten
Amtsinhaber eine absolut seriöse
Persönlichkeit die in der Krise ihre
Stärken gezeigt hat morgen will die
Union entscheiden ob sie einen
Gegenkandidaten oder Kandidatin
aufstellt dies gilt inzwischen aber als
unwahrscheinlich da die drei Ampel
Parteien sich jetzt festgelegt haben
scheint es relativ sicher zu sein dass
Frank-Walter Steinmeier erneut zum
US-Präsidenten gewählt wird für die
Grünen keine leichte Entscheidung als
feministische Partei hätten sie lieber
eine Frau erstmals in diesem Amt gesehen
aber da SPD und FDP sich festgelegt
hatten war die Wahrung des
Koalitionskriegen anscheinend wichtiger
dass nun wohl doch keine Frau ins
Schloss Bellevue einziehen wird für die
Opposition eine verpasste Chance eine
Bundespräsidentin wäre ein starkes
Zeichen gewesen heißt es aus der Union
wie kann es sein dass in der
katholischen Kirche tausenden Kindern
und Jugendlichen sexualisierte Gewalt
angetan werden konnte das die Kirche
Täter deckte im Umgang mit einem dieser
Täter werden dem emeritierten Papst
Benedikt den 16 in seiner Zeit als
Erzbischof von München und Freising
schwere Versäumnisse vorgeworfen in
einem bisher geheim gehaltenen Kirchen
Dokument Michael Habereder berichtet
Markus Elsner war 11 Jahre alt und
Messdiener in Bottrop als es passierte
der Priester nahm ihn mit in seine
Wohnung und Trank mit dem Jungen hinter
diesen Fenstern Wein deswegen mit dieser
Streusel aus und dann
hat er mich heute auch angefasst und er
hat mir an mir gezeigt was ich bei ihm
machen soll also ich musste ihn dann
oral befriedigen
[Applaus]
deine Pflicht gewesen wäre und insofern
Kirchen rechtswidrig gehandelt der
Privatsekretär des ehemaligen Papst ist
das zurück da er von den Vorwürfen
sexuelle Übergriffe keine Kenntnis hatte
bestand auch keine Pflicht zur Meldung
nach Rom dir hätte verletzen können
feststeht auch nach seiner Versetzung
nach Bayern hat Priester h wieder Jungen
missbraucht ein Gutachten dass die
Erzdiözese München Freising in Auftrag
gegeben hat soll nun Aufklärung bringen
alle Akten zum Fall des Priesters
haarseim bereitgestellt worden teilt das
Bistum auf zdf Anfrage mit eine
Veröffentlichung ist für Ende Januar
geplant
Franke nach bei unserem küchenexperten
Jürgen Erbacher guten Abend Herr
Erbacher genommen wie schwerwiegend sind
diese Vorwürfe gefordert eine besondere
Brisanz weil alle Beteiligten noch leben
und mit Joseph Ratzinger eben ein
späterer Papst involviert ist auch auf
den amtierenden Erzbischof von München
und Freising wirkt wirft dieses Dekret
ein schlechtes Licht mit Blick auf
Joseph Ratzinger muss man sagen steht im
Moment Aussage gegen Aussage das Dekret
legt nahe er wusste von der
Vorgeschichte dieses Priesters er sagt
bis heute nein selbst wenn das stimmte
wirft es ein schlechtes Licht auf ihn
nämlich in Bezug auf die Amtsführung als
Erzbischof da muss er über solche Fälle
informiert sein die Hoffnung ruht jetzt
auf dem Gutachten das Ende Januar
vorgestellt wird dann hoffen wir dass
Klarheit herrscht wer welche
Verantwortung hatte und was bedeutet das
für den derzeitigen Erzbischof Kardinal
Marx er dieses Küche geht die credia
geheim gehalten hat der Vorgang zeigt
einmal mehr dass es mit Blick auf
Transparenz bei der Aufarbeitung
sexualisierter Gewalt in der Kirche noch
an vielem mangelt experten sagen Dekret
wirft auch dem Kardinal Marx
Fehlverhalten vor er hatte ja im letzten
Sommer seinen Rücktritt angeboten weil
er Verantwortung übernehmen wollte mit
Blick auf das Versagen des Systems aber
auch persönliche Fehler der Papst hat
gesagt nein Mark sagte damals vielleicht
kommt ein späterer Zeitpunkt wo ich den
Rücktritt noch mal anbieten werde wir
werden jetzt sehen was das Gutachten in
München sagt mit Blick auf ihn und auch
aus seinem früheren Bistum Trier gibt es
Vorwürfe von Betroffenen dass er Fehler
gemacht habe da soll es im Sommer ein
erstes erste Ergebnisse von
Untersuchungen geben der Erzbischof von
München sitzt aktuell auf einem
wackeligen Stuhl dann diese Einschätzung
Erbacher
was wusste der frühere Papst
einer möglichen Rolle bei der
Vertuschung sexualisierter Gewalt in der
katholischen Kirche haben wir online und
in der ZDF heute App für Sie
zusammengefasst
ob eine Impfpflicht Sinn macht hängt
nach Überzeugung des Bundes
Justizministers auch davon ab wie lange
die Impfstoffe wirken wenn es im Februar
März belastbare Anhaltspunkte dafür gibt
dass die Impfpflicht eine deutliche
Vergrößerung des Freiheit Spielraums für
uns alle bringt dann spricht viel dafür
sagte Buschmann der Zeit sollte das
Impfen hingegen absehbar nur für 2-3
Monate helfen dann spricht das eher
gegen eine Impfpflicht
gegen eine allgemeine Impfpflicht und
die Corona Maßnahmen sind gestern Abend
10 000 Menschen in mehreren
Bundesländern auf die Straße gegangen
heiß unangemeldet es kam auch zu
Ausschreitungen Thomas Gonser über die
Proteste und die Hintergründe
[Applaus]
und nicht weiter Magdeburg eine nicht
angekündigte Demo endet an einer
Polizeikette mit Gewalt und mit
Festnahmen
Auseinandersetzungen auf weiter westlich
Fulda die Corona Zahnen hier hoch im
Maßnahmen strikt die Wut groß
friedlicher die Lage in Mannheim
Radikalisierung er verbal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer sich dieser Staat in Amerika
[Musik]
das ganz sicher auch mehr sein
miteinander reden trotzdem wichtig und
sich entgegenstellen in Mannheim gestern
auch das Gegendemonstranten vereint auch
gegen die die die Gesellschaft spalten
wollen
in einer
Präsident
Landeskriminalamt
die USA haben erstmals seit Beginn der
Pandemie mehr als eine Million Corona
Neuinfektionen bin eines Tages
registriert ein neuer weltweiter
Höchstwert ähnlich wie in Europa breitet
sich dort die besonders ansteckende
Omicron Variante in rasantem Tempo aus
auch immer mehr Kliniken schlagen wegen
Fehler Krankmeldungen beim Personal
Alarm
zurück nach Deutschland mit einem Blick
auf den Arbeitsmarkt der ist weiter
stabil die Bundesagentur für Arbeit
registrierte für Dezember
2313001 lose 12000 mehr als im November
die Quote liegt unverändert bei 5,1%
verglichen mit dem Dezember des
Vorjahres gegen die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen um 378 000 zurück
der britische Prinz Andrew soll ich als
17 jährige sexualisierte Gewalt angetan
haben sagt US-Amerikanern und Virginia
Geoffrey und klagt in New York auf
Schmerzensgeld Prinz Andrew war mit dem
Verstorbenen US Sexualstraftäter und
Multimillionär Apps den befreundet denn
so früh zum Sex gezwungen und dann
Andrew vermittelt haben soll sophie
hatte von Apps zum Geld erhalten gegen
eine Verpflichtung zu schweigen
wasserjäger
es ist
Prinz Andrew der Sohn der Queen wegen
sexuellen Missbrauchs angeklagt werden
oder nicht eine Anhörung im fernen New
York sollte das jetzt klären Virginia
hatte schwere Vorwürfe erhoben gestern
veröffentlicht zwischen ihr und dem
Verstorbenen Sexualstraftäter
könnten
für eine halbe Million
durch die Vereinbarung
erledigt an doch viele Rechtsexperten
halten diese für nicht haltbar
das ist einer der bizarrsten dies die
ich je gesehen habe ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass ein Gericht zustimmen
würde das jeder der Virginia je etwas
getan hat und den Apps Dienst Dunstkreis
war jetzt aus der Verantwortung
entlassen wird
seit Monaten
veröffentlicht
hierzulande erleben wir gerade einen
sehr milden Winter in den USA dagegen
hat einen Schneesturm Teile der Ostküste
lahmgelegt 20 cm Neuschnee in Washington
das Chaos war perfekt
AutofahrerInnen hatten zu kämpfen
Schulen Behörden blieben geschlossen für
100000 fiel der Strom aus Flüge mussten
gestrichen werden selbst der
US-Präsident konnte erst aus deiner Air
Force One aussteigen als die Schneedecke
geräumt war
jetzt so einmal eigenes das eigentlich
als unbeschwertes Sportfest gedacht ist
doch das werden die Olympischen
Winterspiele in Peking sicher nicht in
genau einem Monat soll es losgehen vom
4. bis zum 20 Uhr Februar werden sich
dann gut 2.000 Sportlerinnen und
Sportler miteinander messen
überschattet vom diplomatischen Boykott
der USA und anderer Länder weil China
immer wieder die Menschenrechte verletzt
und natürlich auch überschattet von
Corona und den rigiden Maßnahmen dagegen
Christiane Hoffmann
Pompöös inszeniert wie Präsident hieß
Neujahrsansprache soll auch die
Olympischen Spiele werden sie bilden den
Auftakt zu einem wichtigen Jahr für Ski
und seine Partei der Präsident soll
erneut ernannt werden vielleicht auf
Lebenszeit die Spiele vorher perfekt
sein
die Welt wird ihre Augen auf China
richten China ist bereit
gleichzeitig geht die Regierung in
Hongkong weiter gegen Aktivisten vor
schafft endgültig die Demokratie ab
innerhalb Chinas erscheint die Corona
Pandemie längst als Mittel für noch mehr
Kontrolle im Land die Bewegungsfreiheit
eingeschränkt und schon bei wenigen
Corona Fällen werden Millionenstädte
visieren oder heute judro in Loguetown
versetzt
die Abschaffung der Demokratie in
Hongkong die Unterdrückung der Uiguren
in den Junk und immer weniger
Freiheitsrechte für alle Chinesen
presidenti und seine Regierung setzen
ihren Plan von der totalen Kontrolle
kurz vor den Olympischen Winterspielen
weiter fort und sie werden genau
beobachten wie groß der internationale
Widerspruch ist oder ob sie eine Art
Freifahrtschein haben auch die Olympia
Teilnehmer müssen sich auf ständige
Kontrollen und Corona Test einstellen
sowie an diesem Checkpoint sie dürfen
sich nur in drei olympischen Zonen
bewegen werden von der chinesischen
Bevölkerung abgeschirmt begründet wird
das alles mit dem 0 Corona Ziel dem
müssen selbst die Olympischen
Winterspiele folgen
und wir bleiben beim Wintersport und
kommen zu einer im wahrsten Sinn des
Wortes stürmischen Vierschanzentournee
normannische zum zweiten Mal zu einer
drei Schanzen Tournee geworden denn der
Wettbewerb in Innsbruck der musst du
heute Nachmittag wegen starker föhnwinde
abgesagt werden dafür wird es morgen und
übermorgen beim Abschluss in
Bischofshofen zwei Wettbewerbe geben
nach drei Stunden des Wartens die
Gewissheit. Ich schon als Kaiser der
Renndirektor sagte den Wettbewerb ab der
Wind am Bergisel zu gefährlich die
deutsche Jagd auf den Tournee führenden
re Jojo Kobayashi verschoben beide
ausstehenden springen finden in
Bischofshofen statt
einfach so gut momentan das egal ist ein
Wunder geschehen
12 Meter Rückstand muss er aufholen der
Tross zieht weiter der Tournee Ausgang
ist weiter offen
Langläufer Friedrich moch ist bei der
letzten Etappe der Tour de Ski völlig
überraschend auf das Podest gestürmt der
21-Jährige landete nach dem steilen
Schlussanstieg in weil die Firma als
dritter erstmals in seiner Karriere auf
dem Treppchen und Lucas Bögl der
komplizierter als vier das erstklassige
deutsche Tagesergebnis Gesamtsieger der
Tour der Norweger Johannes klaebo
wichtiger 2 zu 1 Sieg für das deutsche
Tennis Thiem gegen die USA beim ATP Cup
in Sydney Alexander Zverev und Jan
Lennard Struff gewannen ihre einzeln das
Doppel die USA damit hat Deutschland die
Chance auf den Einzug ins Halbfinale
gewahrt
Peter Wright hat in London zum zweiten
Mal die Darts WM gewonnen der Schotte
setzte sich gestern Abend in einem
packenden Finale mit sieben zu fünf
Sätzen gegen den Engländer Michael Smith
durch der damit sein zweites WM Finale
verlor das Preisgeld für den stolzen
Sieger 500 000 Pfund der Zweitplatzierte
Smith bekam 200 000
immerhin ein kleines Trostpflaster hin
für den völlig enttäuschten Engländer
wasserabsperrung her und der Deutsche
Wetterdienst warnt aktuell vor
ergiebigen Dauerregen im Schwarzwald der
Regen geht morgen in Schnee über ob der
im Flachland liegen bleibt erklärt
gleich Katja horneffer das heute journal
können Sie um 21:45 Uhr sehen mit
Marietta Slomka machen wir es gut
[Musik]
guten Abend am Oberrhein hat das Tief
Annette bereits mehr als 50 Liter Regen
pro Quadratmeter gebracht es zieht jetzt
morgen weiter nach Osten aber das
nächste Tief das dauert hier schon über
dem Atlantik ist peilt Island an und
dazwischen gibt's ein kleines
Zwischenhoch dass uns am Donnerstag dann
von Westen kurzzeitig beehrt aber heute
Nacht fällt noch kräftiger Regen und
zwar im Nordschwarzwald und in den
Mittelgebirgen am Alpenrand geht der
Regen mehr und mehr in Schnee über an
der Nordseeküste sind doch einige
Gewitter nicht ganz ausgeschlossen und
glatt auf den Straßen kann es eigentlich
überall sein denn fast überall ist es
kalt genug für Glätte mit
Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen +3 und -2
Grad die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen meist du bei 45 Grad kühler
bleibt es in den Mittelgebirgen etwas
milder wird das an der Nordsee morgen
vormittag fällt noch Schneeregen hier im
Südosten Bayerns ein freundlicher
Streifen schließt sich an von der
Uckermark bis zum Saarland und zum
Oberrhein in Nordwesten gibt kräftige
Schauer Schnee Regen und Graupelschauer
und an der Nordsee ist noch Gewitter
dabei der Wind dazu kommt aus westlichen
Richtungen nachmittags verzieht sich der
etwas voll nicht ihre Streifen weiter
nach Süden am Donnerstag wird
freundlicher am Freitag kommen von
Westen schon neue Schnee und Regenfälle
ab guten Abend